opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
what really stands out and this is true
not only of this bowl but pretty much
every poll is that joe biden's numbers
are so bad
tonight on politics now exclusive eight
news now polling with emerson college we
break down all the key races and the
effect a very unpopular president is
having on local races plus how much
money is too much when it comes to
school safety the big price tag to
outfit one local high school campus
and why a police union wants a district
court judge to step down
from eight news now
this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler tonight we
have a clear early look at how the
general election is shaping up from new
eight news now polling with emerson
college and the hill it largely shows
democrat incumbents with slight leads
but they're very tight races this is a
look at the senate race incumbent
democrat catherine cortez masso at this
point in our polling leads republican
adam laxalt by a little more than three
points that's just outside the margin of
error one area of concern though for the
senator could be hispanic voters she has
46 percent support among the latino
community in the governor's race
incumbent steve sisolak leads republican
challenger sheriff joe lombardo by three
points that's right outside the margin
of error of 2.1 percent we also looked
at how much president joe biden's
terrible approval ratings are dragging
down democrats as you see on your screen
here according to our polling mr biden
has just a 32 and a half percent
approval rating in nevada governor
sislak was close to eight points better
las vegas review journal politics editor
steve sibelius says that may encourage
local democrats to keep the president at
a distance
what really stands out and this is true
not only of this poll but pretty much
every poll is that joe biden's numbers
are so bad
um
he really has a huge deficit uh to
overcome and whether or not that deficit
is going to trickle down to other
candidates democratic candidates i think
is is a legitimate question
trump was here to campaign for joe
lombardo and adam laxalt you will not
see joe biden here at the campaign for
catherine cortez-masto and steve cyslak
governor steve siselak was in carson
city this week he spoke with ktvn in
reno about our polling
we're working hard every day on the
campaign side to get our message out
there and i'm confident once people see
what we stand for versus what my
opponent stands for we're going to be
fine the lombardo campaign sent us this
statement it says quote it's no surprise
the majority of nevadans feel our
state's moving in the wrong direction
under steve sisilak the statement goes
on to say they tell me how they're
struggling to pay for gas and groceries
referring to nevadans how they are how
worried they are about their children's
education and how they feel let down by
steve sisilak and joe biden
it is pretty close
i was actually kind of surprised given
all the publicity and all the attacks
that he has endured
during some of these primary races that
that he is ahead as far as he is he's up
by 3.2 percent i'm sorry 3.2 points
over over joe lombardo i think some of
that has to do with the fact that he's
better known
he's known statewide joe lombard was
just introducing himself still to people
in northern
nevada and he had a very bruising
primary fight
the numbers for somebody else and
undecided are still pretty large in that
race so there's a lot of room for either
candidate to maneuver i think
recently nevada democratic lawmakers
redrew congressional boundaries their
goal was to spread out enough of their
supporters to keep swing districts safe
right now though it's left all three
races with democratic incumbents in
southern nevada very close in district
one you can see from our polling again
incumbent democrat dina titus holds a
four and a half point lead over
republican challenger mark robertson
nearly 17 percent though are undecided
in northern nevada's district 2
incumbent republican mark yamaday leads
his challenger by about 11 points
incumbent democrat susie lee leads her
race in district 3 by our polling by
just two points over republican april
becker 13 percent are undecided and in
district four democrat stephen horsford
has a similar lead in a battle to keep
serving that district he leads sam
peters by again about three points once
again 13 percent though are undecided
still the trends are
looking towards a red wave uh in
november and
and i don't think candidates can rely on
that and just sit back on their laurels
each individual candidate in each
individual race can have to make a case
for himself or herself
but i think at this point it's pretty
much even and it's either party could go
either way and individual races
individual issues are going to be a big
important part before election day
still many months to go most nevadans
are not happy with the direction the
state is heading more of our polling
numbers here about 55 percent of those
we polled say nevada is on the wrong
track the most pressing issue the
economy number two and three those you
can see from this polling are a bit of a
change from our last polling water
supply the second most important issue
facing nevada followed by education and
housing but it really is the economy
that overshadows everything so who's to
blame when asked what is responsible for
rising inflation pollsters we spoke with
say more than 42 percent blame the bind
administration far behind supply chain
disruptions and the war in ukraine on
gas prices the story is the same 46
percent of nevada voters blame president
biden and his policies after that oil
companies and sanctions against russia
emerson college's spencer kimball helped
conduct the poll for us we asked him to
break down some of the trends he saw
the democrats have been struggling to
hold on to some of that latino vote does
the polling show that as well that maybe
some of that latino vote is not with the
democrats as it has been in the past
well certainly the latino vote is
swinging we're doing a national study
looking just at that and we see it you
know prime example here in nevada where
uh look at donald trump he loses the
state but now when we asked the hispanic
votes how they would vote they're kind
of split between trump and biden and in
2020 he loses the hispanic vote by 2025
points so you're beginning to see that
shift and that's primarily due to
economic reasons
what else does the polling show folks in
nevada are concerned about right now
well yes the economy is number one in
affordable housing and or housing
affordability is number two but what's
really interesting in in out out west is
water issues and that's where sysel act
the the governor is doing very well and
kind of holding his own on that issue of
water rights and water access so we're
going to have to see how this issue this
is a regional issue but it's going to
play very strong here in the silver
state and we're going to have to see how
it plays over time right now the
democrats are doing very well on this
issue and it's hurt it's helping both in
the senate and the governor race broadly
what does what are some of the main
takeaways from this polling about where
nevada
polling and where nevada voters are
right now
as they're getting ready to make
decisions in november
well right now the voters are very
concerned about gas prices the cost of
inflation we see that in the economic
numbers we see that in the blame game
they're blaming president biden
generally for inflation
they're a bit of a split i think the
democrats have done a better job of
being able to
on the gas issue look at corporate greed
and gouging as an alternative to blaming
the biden administration
and we're kind of seeing that in these
numbers regarding a new sports stadium
it looks like
the football stadium was the last one
that the voters want to support
one major question will be just how much
of a drag president joe biden's bad
approval ratings will be on the rest of
the ticket julia manchester's with the
hill
so if the leader of the democratic party
right now is not looked favorably upon
by democrats i think that could lead to
some serious questions uh as to how big
will uh democratic turnout be in nevada
come november you know will uh
independent voters will democrats even
you know vote for the democratic party
or will they switch the republican party
i think we can definitely say that the
majority of democrats will likely vote
along party lines in the midterms but
what i mean is that we should really
look at those independent or swing
voters in areas like las vegas for
example um that could very much decide
many of these elections i think if
you're a vulnerable incumbent like
catherine fortes mask masso steve
sissellach suzy lee deena titus you're
looking at this poll in biden's approval
ratings and you're wanting to take a
step back from the president and wanting
to you know focus on your own profile in
the state and your own record in order
to really distance yourself from him you
can see a lot more of our polling that
we've done on 8newsnow.com including
some polling on people's opinions on
abortion and the ongoing january 6th
hearings and we plan to do more of these
polls in the election cycle
this week republican senate candidate
adam laxalt went to the texas-mexico
border his campaign posted this video
you're seeing here of his visit down
there
he says mr laxalt says president biden
and senator cortez masto's border
policies have led to the record number
of people who are crossing now illegally
at the same time senator cortez masto
was in washington d.c where a vote on
abortion bills was held we're going to
have a little bit more on that in just a
moment but this week she also reported
raising a record amount of seven and a
half million dollars last quarter that
gives gives her about 10 million dollars
in cash on hand the laxalt campaign did
not release his fundraising tolls by the
time we taped this program
next on politics now what is safety
worth
parents want to know that their children
are safe
the big price tag for security upgrades
at one local school and what the money
is being used for
call 1-800 steemer today
welcome back to politics now
a little more here from our eight news
now emerson college the hill poll turns
out taxpayers here in nevada strongly
oppose using public money for a new
sports stadium you heard spencer kimball
referenced that earlier and they also
want to break up clark county school
district the polling we did shows by a
three to one margin voters want to split
ccsd many state leaders have announced
their support for that as well but as
you can see there are 40 percent of the
people we polled but are unsure about
that
polls show just 17 percent favored
giving money to a new baseball stadium
here in las vegas 750 million dollars in
room tax money is already set aside for
a legion stadium politicians like
governor steve sisilak and joe lombardo
they're running against each other they
also oppose a funding deal for an
oakland a's ballpark
clark county school district is putting
a lot of money into campus security el
dorado high school for example is
getting millions of dollars in upgrades
it comes after the attack and sexual
assault on a teacher there allegedly by
a student but some parents say they're
worried about that money being so
concentrated in just one place sasha
loftus reports
it is very concerning camilla bywaters
is worried about what's to come as a
ccsd parent
parents want to know that their children
are safe she spoke out during thursday's
regular board meeting after information
on emergency security funding for
schools was released
documents show scheduled upgrades at el
dorado high school will cost just over
26 million dollars with the majority of
that money going to secure campus
fencing cctv camera upgrades a single
entry door and an alert system clark
high school will see similar changes to
the tune of about 100 thousand bucks
increasing safety measures for one
school ccsc calls this a life safety
necessity citing violent events like the
recent attack and sexual assault on an
el dorado teacher but speaking as a
local advocate for equity bywaters says
all southern nevada schools deserve the
same treatment it is important that
funding is directed towards safety that
is not a question or an argument but it
also needs to be equitable across our
district so every student can feel
comfortable in the classroom how can we
support
all schools and ensuring that all
students all staff all teachers have
safe schools to come to
and that was sasha loftus reporting ccsd
says each school building each campus
has unique needs based on its
infrastructure and so the costs vary we
did ask the district for an itemized
list of upgrades and expenses especially
that 26 million dollars but the district
says it is keeping that confidential
more calls for resignation a metro
police union wants district court judge
erica ballou to step down for comments
that she made in the courtroom now the
head of the commission which
investigates nevada judges tells 8 news
now it is aware of the incident which
was recorded
you're a black man in america you know
you don't want to be nowhere where cops
are listen i listen to you you listen to
me you know you don't want to be nowhere
where cops are because i know i don't
and i'm a middle-aged middle-class black
woman i don't want to be around where
the cops are because i don't know if i'm
gonna walk away alive or not
judge baloo made those comments during a
probation hearing the suspect in the
case is accused of committing battery
against an officer while still on
probation for another crime in a
statement to 8 news now judge baloo says
she supports proper law enforcement and
was trying to be straightforward and
understandable to the defendant the
judicial commission in nevada says it
will consider all complaints that it
receives about this incident
should we be concerned about tick tock
next on politics now the national
security objections being raised to the
social media app
plus will the senate pass any abortion
bills why democrats are trying to force
votes they know won't pass
[Music]
you're watching politics now
a man who chased governor steve sisilak
at a restaurant earlier this year has
taken his own life the 8 news now i-team
has learned 38-year-old justin andersich
died of a self-inflicted gunshot wound
last weekend metro police say they were
interviewing his partner about an
alleged domestic disturbance andersitch
arrived back at the scene and that's
when officers say he took his own life
in february he posted video of himself
chasing and threatening the governor and
first lady kathy sisselak
andersitch's father tells the i-team his
family is meeting with investigators now
to learn more about what happened
back in washington a series of new
abortion legislation was introduced by
democrats didn't make it out of the
senate though the bills would have
restored access to abortion nationwide
it also would protect access to
contraception as conservative states eye
restrictions beyond abortion this of
course after the overturning of roe v
wade democrats say health providers are
stuck trying to violate state law they
also have several bills aimed at
protecting access to contraception
that's something republican senator
roger marshall says is unnecessary
every state abortion law triggered by
overturning roe includes an exception to
save the life of the mother some have
already been instructed to observe
patients until they have unstable vital
signs before acting that is absolutely
barbaric
joining us is alexandra limon from our
washington d.c bureau alex planned
parenthood in nevada says it's already
seeing women coming here from other
states to get abortions how would this
legislation have protected them
hey there john well what democratic
senators were trying to do was to pass a
federal law that would basically
invalidate any state laws from states
that were trying to ban women from
traveling across state lines to access
abortions
and it would have invalidated those laws
and would have given the doj for example
the authority to go after states if they
didn't indeed try to violate
those restrictions it
we've heard a lot about this issue and
part of this is that some clinics are
also concerned that they'll just be
overwhelmed by the sheer number of
people who are coming to the clinics why
did democrats call for the vote now
you we kind of know they didn't have
much of a chance of passing
right and they knew that which is in
part why they called for this as a
unanimous consent vote and what they're
trying to do here though is to they said
to themselves democratic senators to
showcase the differences between the
democratic party and republicans keep in
mind we are heading into a november
midterm election and democrats are
hopeful that this issue is really going
to galvanize their voters and really
maybe they're trying to connect with
women suburban women women who are
undecided voters who can go either way
on an issue that they feel is important
to that base because you know we hear
democratic senators lawmakers in general
talk about this a lot that
new restrictive measures on abortions
won't necessarily have the effect of
driving down the number of abortions
instead they may instead cause women to
seek dangerous alternative ways to have
abortions and so they really do feel
that this is an issue
that is important to their base and that
could drive people to vote
in the upcoming november election
and that was alex simone from washington
d.c nevada already has the most
permissive abortion law in the country
24 weeks a lot of those other things
being considered including access to
birth control are already in nevada law
tick tock is stirring up concern from
federal lawmakers and leaders they're
sounding the alarm after new reports
show the private data of some users here
in the u.s might not be so private
hannah brandt explains why some say
that's a national security risk
the popular app tick tock has millions
of u.s users and recent reporting from
buzzfeed news set off alarm bells when
it revealed that china is accessing
their data it was really disturbing to
me
knowing what we know about china's
nefarious intentions experts here china
could use the data for things like
targeted blackmail political
manipulation and advancing artificial
intelligence to have china have access
to that it should scare the dickens out
of all of us this is a security concern
that's why senator mark warner and
senator marco rubio teamed up to ask the
federal trade commission to investigate
tick tock there are a whole litany of of
tools that the federal trade commission
can use in these kind of deceptive
practices acts and federal
communications commissioner brendan carr
is pressuring google and apple to remove
tick tock from their app stores he also
wants to see federal agencies get
involved whether it's the ftc
treasury commerce we take immediate
action uh and stop these surreptitious
flows of data back into china but
virginia tech cyber security expert
aaron brantley is looking to lawmakers
for a legislative solution to require
onshoring of u.s national data he says
then private data wouldn't be allowed to
leave the u.s without specific legal
permission senator warner doesn't think
full onshoring is the solution but
believes national data privacy
regulations are long overdue tick tock
is quite popular but it shouldn't be
that popularity at the cost of
every american's individual privacy in
washington i'm hannah brandt
back here in las vegas next week las
vegas city council members will discuss
a new curfew in and around the fremont
street experience the proposal restricts
anyone under 21 from the area from 9 pm
through 5 a.m 7 days a week and if
someone is underaged they'd have to be
with a parent or a guardian the
heightened concern comes after two
shootings at the fremont street
experience over the last month one of
them deadly
next on politics now a journey back in
time we'll take a look at some amazing
images pouring in from nasa's newest
telescope and what nasa hopes to achieve
on politics now
[Music]
you're watching politics now
finally here on politics now we want to
leave you with some amazing images from
space this is karina nebula 7 600 light
years away just out of the reach of our
polling that means it's traveling at the
speed of light it would take you 7 600
years to get there it's one of the
amazing pictures that we got of our
universe from nasa's james webb space
telescope they're fantastic
absolutely beautiful and they're a real
hint at the power that the observatory
will have
now the hope for james webb the
telescope is that the deeper in seas
into space the deeper back in time we'll
get to see and provide answers more
answers about the birth of our universe
very interesting stuff
that'll do it for us here on politics
now all the latest political news and
even intergalactic news on 8newsnow.com
we're back with you on saturday as well
take care
[Music]